how does tony shay live on it's
interesting because he sort of had a
feather duster and he touched things and
left
little marks there's not this enormous
huge imprint it's by the people
just like sprinkling dust on people
and so you can walk through the city and
say
tony was part of what was here before he
had the great
great opportunity ahead of him
still and i know he was still always
looking for tomorrow always tomorrow
and the dust this very dust that's all
been sprinkled around our community
that to me that is in tony tony is not
this rigid street type thing that they
do for other people
tony's ethereal tony's the spirit
and something else
a park maybe that would be made
for him oh no i can't imagine anything
as boring as a street
something i don't know i see something
that changes
and whether it's a piece of sculpture
that's moving
that an artist or one of our local
artists could create
that was colorful and just moving and i
think
maybe somebody would come forward and
create a competition among
our artists that
i think would be a beautiful way